welcome back to Long crime daily we go
now to Mississippi where a disturbing
story is getting a lot of attention a
man missing since the last fall was
found dead with his head severed from
his body that's according to an
independent autopsy released by his
family despite apparently brutal
injuries at the time rasheem Carter's
body was found the sheriff's department
said no foul play was suspected The
Carter family is now asking for a
federal probe into the investigation
Cardinal's mother says regime told her
he was being targeted by white men in
the community then just days later he
went missing according to the family's
Attorney Ben Crump Carter Carter's head
was removed and his spinal cord was
found in a different area some of his
body parts are reportedly still missing
the Mississippi State medical examiner's
report states that the conditions of the
remains make it difficult to pinpoint
the time of death the report lists both
the cause and manner of death as
undetermined
this was a nefarious Act
this was a evil Act
Racine Carter
and we cannot let them get away with
this
on um
October the 1st
my son texted me
this was after uh him and I had gotten
off the phone he said me and the owner
of this company not singing eye to eye
Mama his name
which I can't say at this time but if
anything happened to me he's responsible
for it I'm too smart mama he got these
guys wanting to kill me
and that's what he said to me
and then he went missing
Nemo what sentence does it make for the
police to say there is no evidence of
Foul Play he didn't dismember himself
yeah that's a very poor statement by law
enforcement down there in Mississippi
because in four months they really
haven't been able to figure out what
happened here and at best you know you
have wild animals and the body parts are
scattered over two acres but this is the
type of case you know I'm team Bank
Crump you got to get the feds involved
here you got to figure out what happened
because if Mom is right and he was
really being chased by three truckloads
of white men they have a potential
motive here you may have a hate crime
you have a murderer and if you can't
figure it out law enforcement you gotta
get feds involved so they can yeah I'm
getting really a mod Aubrey Vibes here
and I'm not liking it law enforcement
said they are waiting for the results of
search warrants to rule out Foul Play
what do you think they're searching for
at this point well you know the
statement that he made to his mother and
that's in a text so they can take a look
at that specifically name the individual
he thought was behind this truckload of
white men he said in the community
chasing him so that's where they need to
start they need to invest gate and
interview that particular individual and
frankly as far as I'm concerned they
need to track his phone they need to
track his car they need to do GPS and
they need to check any of the
individuals he may have communicated
with because that's going to tell us
what happened to the victim on this day
because we know that he couldn't have
decapitated himself Terry are you born
in Mississippi we should send you there
to start the investigation I think we'll
wrap this up pretty quickly well another
family begging for justice and the death
of their child it's it's been more than
four months since janquila Robinson died
in Cabo Mexico her family is demanding
the U.S government step up and get
involved Robinson died from severe
injuries to her head and spine after an
apparent beating that contradicts the
initial report that she needed medical
treatment because of alcohol poisoning
videos shared on social media after her
death appeared to show shinkuala being
beaten her family believes someone
traveling with her was the aggressor and
Mexican authorities agree they issue
arrest warrants and claim they are
working with U.S officials on
extradition but it hasn't happened yet
so Robinson's family is now appealing
directly to President Joe Biden and
Secretary of the State Anthony blinken
to help them get Justice the FBI is
reportedly investigating but no charges
have been filed
and in other news the son of imprisoned
reality TV stars Todd and Julie Chrisley
Kyle is himself facing charges he's
accused of pulling a knife on a
supervisor at work 32 year old Kyle
Chrisley is charged with aggravated
assault in Tennessee according to police
cursey worked for Penske Truck Rental
and got into an altercation with the
supervisor reportedly hitting him in the
face and upper body Chrisley also
allegedly pulled out a knife and
threatened to stab the victim Chrisley
turned himself in on Tuesday his father
Todd and stepmother Julie are
incarcerated separately as they serve
out multi-year sentences for fraud they
were convicted of obtaining fraudulent
loans to pay for their lavish lifestyle
Kyle Chrisley has a court date scheduled
for the end of the month
coming up on Law and crime daily Netflix
was hit with a defamation suit for one
of their most watched documentaries why
a former detective says the series got
the story all wrong and what a judge
ultimately decided
to finish off today's show we want to
talk about Netflix the media giant just
won a defamation suit against a retired
detective that involved their hit series
making a murderer the 10 pot documentary
aired in 2015 covering the story of
Wisconsin man Stephen Avery he spent
more than two decades in prison for
sexual assault but was exonerated in
2003 with the help of DNA technology
four years later he would be once again
convicted and sentenced to life in
prison alongside his nephew this time
for the 2005 rape and murder of a female
photographer the docky series raised
speculation about the case's local law
enforcement and if there was a
possibility that Avery and his nephew
could have been framed as a result
former detective Andrew Coburn sued
Netflix for defamation in 2019. he
claimed that the series misquoted and
misrepresented his testimony through
editing making him falsely appear
nervous and uncertain on Friday a U.S
District Judge ruled in favor of the
series and two of its filmmakers
concluding that Colburn did not prove
they acted with actual malice against
him
why does a suit against an officer have
to show actual malice and was the judge
right to not find any
Ryan the judge was right if you're a
police officer and you're a public
figure you're entitled to less
protection than you would be an ordinary
individual who's just working in private
so you know we saw this with Johnny Depp
you know and a public figure doesn't
mean someone has a blue check mark on
Instagram or take that this is someone
who's acting and puts himself or herself
out in the public and Malice requires
actual knowledge of the truth or
Reckless disregard you gotta meet that
higher standard to win a defamation case
in the sheriff here just was unable to
do so so the judge got it right decided
with Netflix on First Amendment grounds
all right blue check mark or not you
still got approve actual amounts Terry
do you think this definition case will
have any impact on the film industry
moving forward I do and I agree with
Nema the judge did get it right here
Netflix had every right to do this story
and as long as they did their research
as long as they gave both sides an
opportunity to speak there should be no
defamation claim here now in a normal
defamation case where there's not a
public figure you just need a false
statement there should be some
negligence there you should have some
injury as far as the individual claiming
that he was defamed or she was defamed
and then you can actually bring the case
forward I think in the future we're
going to see so many documentaries and
you're going to see that they're going
to be very careful about how they do it
and the Very nature of a documentary is
it's supposed to be a true story so in
those instances you don't have as much
leeway as you might have in a movie or
something based on a true story so good
thing that the judge ruled in the proper
way here but I definitely think that any
person who is developing a documentary
is going to be a little bit more careful
not to be sued actually meme I got a few
more seconds I want to throw this
question to you what if this wasn't a
public figure what if there was no need
for actual malice do you think this
would have ended up differently
potentially yes but you know I mean
let's talk about these documentaries and
how important they've been you know Bob
Durst brought to Justice because of a
documentary R Kelly documentary uh
Britney Spears freed from a
conservatives because of a documentary I
mean judges are you know they're
ordinary human beings and they're going
to say look is this gonna have a
chilling effect or are these
documentaries doing a public good are
they doing something good for a criminal
justice system and I think they are
Brian yeah I would agree with you there
don't make any documentaries about me
though I don't need to get any kind of
trouble well Mima Terry thank you very
much and thank you for joining us here
on Long crime daily we'll see you next
time as we discuss Justice in America
[Music]
thank you